this is a production of cornell
university
great so yeah today i'm going to be
talking about one aspect of my work
thinking about agriculture within the
earth system and and the interactions
that it can have with climate
so my research really broadly focuses on
thinking about how how terrestrial
ecosystems interact within our climate
system meaning how they
hit how they
respond to climate change how they
contribute to climate change and really
how humans have changed those
interactions
and so today i'll be thinking about one
specific aspect of this agricultural
management but i just want to emphasize
how important plants are within this
climate system and i'll do that by
starting to look at this carbon dioxide
concentration curve the healing curve
which i'm sure that you are all familiar
with just my pointer work yes so as you
um
as you'll see from this curve and you
all likely know
concentrations of carbon dioxide are
increasing through time and that
increase
is cause is caused in large part by
human activities but what i want to draw
your attention to is this annual cycle
so i'll blow this up here and the reason
that i want you to pay attention to this
annual cycle is because it's driven by
terrestrial productivity specifically in
the northern hemisphere where there's
more land mass and so every year
carbon dioxide when plants start to grow
in the summer in the spring and summer
they take up carbon dioxide and it's
measurable from
you know from these large scale
measurements we see how much carbon
dioxide is being drawn down by plants
every year
and so
while
a single leaf might seem small
we have um when we globally aggregate
plants if you look at the land surface a
lot of it is green and so when we
globally aggregate plants they can have
a really large
measurable influence on climate
processes
uh
there you go and so one
when we change the land surface for
example for agriculture we are changing
how that land surface functions both how
it looks which is really important for
biogeophysical or like energy and water
fluxes and then also biogeochemical
fluxes things like um carbon cycling
nitrogen cycling so we're really
changing how the land looks how it
functions within our earth system
by managing our land and so we use a
suite of tools to try and understand
these processes and these are all tools
that i use in my work
so this includes
empirical data collection this is a
manipulative warming experiment at the
soy face site
environmental and ecological theory and
also earth system models
and using this suite of tools enables a
lot of really exciting science including
generating new hypotheses measuring and
scaling ecological processes so you can
you can scale from your field site to
regional or global scales using models
understanding complex interactions that
are just difficult to disentangle in
in
measurements in systems
also determining the impact of human
decisions we can use models to
understand how those decisions might
change our ecosystems our climate
without actually
doing a large scale experiment on
our climate system
and last to understand the future of our
ecosystems and these are not this is
just a list that i could think of
there's probably additional
exciting things that you can think of
but these are ways that i like to use
this model i'm gonna try and move this
mouse out of the way
and i want to take a quick aside this is
a
cartoon that um
i
i drafted with emily kiker snowman um we
collect a paper thinking about into
putting ecology into models the reason
that i want to
highlight this is because a lot of times
when we collect observations we just
kind of think that they can be stuffed
in models
and
when modelers are working on models they
just think why aren't you giving me the
observations that i need i just i just
want this data to put into the model
um
but really what we need is an
integration of these processes and so we
need to we need to think and understand
across these two
seemingly disparate fields they're not
actually desperate but they can seem
disparate
so we need to
we really need to think about
how to
better integrate these processes and i
feel like
i felt a little bit like dorothy here
where i was stuffing new processes into
models and i would write my papers at
the end of my field work saying this
process should be incorporated in a
global scale model because it's
important for climate
and
i wanted to actually
spend a little bit of time figuring that
out so that's why i ended up and car
working with models trying to
figure out what the climate impact was
of
some of these terrestrial processes
so
that's just
kind of an aside about why i try to use
that integration or that suite of tools
they use and so the model
that i use and i'm going to focus mostly
on or almost entirely i guess on model
simulations today so use the community
earth system model
and as young said this is one of the
large global scale or system models it
contains all of the different components
of the earth system or many of the
components of the earth system so it
contains the atmosphere the land ice the
land ocean and sea ice and they're all
connected through a coupler so that's
what that
little ball is in the middle
um the thing i like about this diagram
is it's actually the
little bubbles are scaled by the number
of lines of code the size of the bubble
so you can see the atmosphere has the
most lines of code the land model has
the second most land
lines of code
there's over 2 million lines of code in
this model it's a really large model
it's used by the international community
to understand climate change it's
probably the most widely used persistent
model that we have and so this is
developed and maintained by ncar and
it's the model that i will use
throughout my work today
and so like i said it contains all the
different components of the earth system
including the land and most of the
changes that i'm going to make and that
we're going to look at today
will focus on the land model
so i want to highlight really quickly
the land model that is the land
component of this earth system model is
the community land model
which we call clm
so i will be using clm clm
includes a suite of ecological processes
i'm not going to go through all of these
but i want to highlight that these are
broadly categorized as surface energy
fluxes hydrology and biogeochemical
cycles
today i will focus mostly on surface
energy fluxes biogeochemical cycles i
don't do as much work with hydrology but
there is a lot of hydrology included in
these models
if you're interested
um and most of the work that i will
present is going to couple just the land
and the atmosphere components
of this model so you're going to connect
the land
perturb the land see how it changes the
atmosphere and atmospheric processes
so that's kind of the broad scale
overview
the topics that i will cover today will
start with thinking about cover crops
and can cover crop management change air
temperature
and then i'll talk a little bit more in
depth about the crop model that we use
in the community land model and how
agricultural management has changed
global crop yields
then i'll end with thinking about how
agriculture changes seasonal patterns of
carbon dioxide fluxes
so we start with cover crops i have a
suite of collaborators for each of these
projects
um all of whom have been instrumental in
helping
to guide and develop these projects and
so i just want to highlight them as well
i'm guessing that many of you know what
cover crops are but just in case you
don't cover crops or crops that are
planted
during the not normal growing cash crop
growing season and so you can see their
cover crops here on the left but not
here on the right so this is an
experiment that was comparing cover
crops to bare ground
cover crops provide a lot of localized
benefits and so they're widely um used
for the or maybe not widely used but
they are used for these localized
benefits and they include things like
weed and pathogen suppression reducing
erosion runoff nitrogen
leaching
improving soil processes in general
including
infiltration nutrient cycling
and um there's a whole suite of
benefits that i'm not including here but
are very beneficial
and so i wanted to know how do cover
crops impact climate we think a lot
about changing soil carbon related to
agriculture and cover crops
thought about in one of those capacities
and also maintaining soil health
and so i started to think about what are
the potential cover crop climate
feedbacks so on the biogeochemical side
we have carbon going into the system but
also carbon methane and nitrous oxide
being released from the ecosystems and
soil carbon sequestration so there's a
lot of active research actually trying
to understand all of these different
processes on the biogeochemical side
um on the biogeophysical side these are
more related to energy fluxes and so we
can think about cover crops as affecting
surface roughness
a little bit
also albedo so the reflectivity of the
surface and then soil evaporation and
transpiration which collectively call
evapotranspiration
and so
less is known about these biogeophysical
impacts of cover crops so i'm going to
focus today on only looking at these
biogeophysical impacts
and i'm going to ignore the
biogeochemical impacts even though they
are extremely important i'm just not
going to probe that today
so what i would expect when you plant
cover crops so when you go from a bare
ground surface to a vegetated surface
you might get some increase in roughness
and some increase in evapotranspiration
and a decrease in albedo likely it'll be
less reflective
so surface roughness it can help cool
the air
soil
or evapotranspiration so soil
evaporation and
plant transpiration can also help to
pull the air through that evaporative
cooling flux latent heat flux and albedo
if we have less reflectivity
uh we might increase temperature so the
the direction of the impact of each of
the individual terms is opposite to its
impact on temperature and so
the arrows are showing you the direction
that the
the impact of surface roughness of apple
transpiration or albedo will have and
then the boxes around them are showing
you warming or cooling impact of that
so
i
use this er system model to run a very
idealized scenario so this is i'm not
saying that this is realistic at all but
this is one way that we can use a model
is to probe do cover crops have an
impact on climate
and so what i did is i planted cover
crops in all crop regions throughout
north america with the goal of
determining the impact on winter time
temperatures when cover crops are
planted compared to bare ground so
compared to no cover crops and so assume
that all crop area is now covered in
cover crops for this experiment
and to run this experiment like i showed
earlier i'm connecting the land model
with the atmosphere model to understand
how this change in the land surface is
impacting the atmosphere
and what i found is that there is
significant winter warming
in in snow-covered regions so cover
crops may increase these winter
temperatures in snowy regions this is uh
up to a three or three and a half degree
increase in some regions the the
stippling shows you this uh statistical
significance so that's where there's a
statistically significant increase in
temperature this is equivalent to about
a five and a half to six degree increase
in winter temp uh
five to five and a half to six degrees
fahrenheit
increase in winter time temperatures so
it is
it is a definitely a decent amount of
warming
but also
that's because and so part of the reason
why there is this increase is because
cover crops are changing the albedo of
the ecosystem so when we have bare
grounds and it snows you see the snow
but if you have cover crops planted
you see a lot more of the crops sticking
up above the smell and so that's what's
changing the albedo you can see how much
brighter this fairground is compared
to this region with the cover crops so
that's what's driving that temperature
increase
and what i found is when you decrease
the height and this is also true if you
make the cover crops less leafy so maybe
you plant them less densely
you just have sparser cover crops
you minimize that winter warming and so
while we see a trend towards warming
i guess you can't see the bottom axis
because of the zoom bar
but this is uh
it's the same um
same axis temperature axis as before
but what you see is that while there's a
trend towards warming you are minimizing
that warming there's no statistically
significant warming and so to me what
this says
is that if we're going to plant cover
crops
which you know i'm not
we should still consider cover crops
because of all their benefits both on
the carbon sequestration potential side
and also the soil health side but if we
plant cover crops we might want to
consider planting shorter cover crops or
growing or
mowing or grazing them when we do plant
them so that they are shorter than the
um in the snowpack
in these snow-covered regions
so just to
a quick summary of
um of this section of the talk
cover crops may increase winter
temperature that's the impact is
primarily in snowy regions where that
effect of albedo dominates and so it's
this
this the importance of albedo that is
really causing that increase but we have
the potential to minimize that warming
with shorter cover crops or like i said
less leafy cover crops as the other
experiment that we did where we saw a
decrease in that
winter temperature warming
so this is a very idealized scenario it
helps us to understand how we can maybe
manage
our cover crops to mitigate any
potential warming consequences but also
we have no experiments to evaluate this
against i don't know of any experiments
that have actually measured energy
fluxes in cover crop ecosystems a lot of
a lot of the research that i am aware of
has focused primarily on
the
soil health effects and the carbon
effects
rather and and some of the hydrology
impacts as well but not as much the
energy fluxes and so it would be really
great to see
maybe a flux tower in a cover crop field
so that we can better understand or some
other way to think about measuring some
of these energy fluxes so that we can
better understand if
these model simulations are
showing us the actual impact of cover
crops on wintertime temperatures
okay so like i said we are
with agricultural management we are
changing the way the land surface looks
and the way that it functions and so
that's you know this
experiment this cover crop experiment is
just highlighting one example
of that and so next i want to dive into
thinking about agricultural management a
little bit more in depth
and how um so the question that i will
ask is how
agricultural management has changed
global crop yields
but in doing so i will also explain a
little bit about how agriculture is
represented
in the community
land model
so i'm going to dive in and just focus
on land-only impacts right now
um
and and thinking about only having the
land possibly i guess it's a little loud
out there
[Music]
yeah sorry about that can you all you
can all hear me still yeah okay
uh so the way that we represent crops in
the community land model i should
highlight that this is
this model in particular is based on
that agro-ibis model that's what we use
currently we are
doing some new development to
incorporate the apsim
model which is a little bit more
flexible um and will allow
allow us to do a little bit more
the the one thing that i will highlight
is that
the
the way
the crop model that we have in the earth
system model it's
it is
an earth system model first and so i
don't expect this to be as
detail-oriented or as great of a model
as an agronomic model for example that
is looking in more detail but this is a
really useful model like i was just
showing you to try and understand
climate impacts of agriculture and how
agriculture fits within our earth system
and that's something that we often can't
do
in agronomic models
so we represent currently several
different crop types we have temperate
and tropical varieties of corn and soy
so we grow crops
in both temperate and tropical regions
we also have sugar cane cotton
rice we have miscanthus and switchgrass
two of our bio energy crops those are
currently even though
we have ways to simulate them
they're currently not included on our
surface data set and so we need to make
some modifications
to um
to add the regions where these crops are
growing in order to use them more
effectively in the model and then we
also have
a representation of wheat we actually
have two types of wheat that we
represent winter wheat and uh spring
wheat
but we can't just we can't easily
distinguish
where
winter wheat is growing versus where
spring wheat is growing and so it makes
it hard to use
both of those and so for wheat what
we're doing right now is we're currently
simulating all wheat areas as spring
wheat even though
that is not we know that that's not
accurate we just don't have the
capability to disentangle where winter
wheat versus spring wheat is growing at
this time
um and these are this is
these are global data sets i should say
so it's not
uh we can distinguish potentially more
at the regional scale but we don't have
global scale data sets to help us
distinguish
um so we want to highlight also that
agriculture in this model is globally
distributed and so this is
um
i should also say that this is a really
unique capability in an er system model
the community or system model is the
only model that includes a comprehensive
representation of agriculture and the
reason that i thought of that here is
because
most of the time these when earth system
models do include agriculture which they
do occasionally they only include it in
temperate regions
so usually it's
you know they'll have some agriculture
in north america
in
um in europe and in parts of asia but
they don't include it globally which
makes it really hard to understand the
impact that agriculture has and
additionally
uh in the community land model we have a
global crop area changing through time
and again this is a unique feature
within an earth system model because
most our system models do not include
the temporal change in distributions of
crops they can include
crops for present day
there's only one other model that has
global distributions of crops and it's
only for present day so these aren't
used in the climate simulations that
we're
trying to use to understand our earth
system and how climate change is
happening
um
except for in cesm so cesm is the only
model that includes this kind of
comprehensive representation of
agriculture and agricultural management
so globally distributed and time varying
which is important for understanding the
impacts that crops have had over time
the way that phenology is currently
represented as i said this is based on
the agro-ibis model
there's four triggers there's
a planting
trigger there's a leaf emergence trigger
a grain filled trigger and a harvest
trigger and these phenological phases
are all triggered by temperature
so like i said forthcoming developments
will allow for more realistic phenology
including triggers that are based on
moisture stress
and other types of stressors
we do include two types of management
currently we have fertilization and
irrigation fertilization we apply manure
um it's two grams of nitrogen per meter
squared per year it's globally constant
in all agriculture areas
and then chemical fertilizer this is
prescribed by crop type by year and by
country so this does change through
space and through time
irrigation we have
a few different application methods and
a few different water sources i'm really
sorry the zoom is cutting off the bottom
of the slide because you're missing some
of the information but the application
methods are the drip irrigation which is
actually our defaults and then there's
also sprinkler irrigation and flood
irrigation is under development there's
a paper that's just been submitted with
that new development the water sources
that we have are rivers and surface
waters which is default we also have
groundwater and then reservoirs
are being developed in cesm right now
so yeah that's what you can't see on the
bottom of this slide
so how well does clm simulate crop
yields like i said this is not intended
to be an agronomic model so it's not i
don't expect it to be perfect
um
but this is global crop production so
this is frame production in terms of
millions of tons
through time and so we always start
simulations in the 1850s
clm is in black we don't have
observational data back as early as 1850
and so from 1850 to 1950
we see a linear increase in crop yields
through time
and then that increase starts to ramp up
after the 1950s
so
sort of it's
reasonably similar to
fao estimates of global grain yields
um which is exciting for us because we
didn't do much tuning of this model but
then when you start to reach the 1980s
1990s
clm crop yields level off whereas fao
yields increase
and this that the reason that i think
that there is this discrepancy is
because clm does not include any
processes related to agricultural
intensification which really started to
ramp up in the 80s and 90s
so there are things like changes in
cultivars changes in plant intensity
changes in technology that have all
increased yields continued this linear
upward increase where clm does not
include that so yields stagnate over
that time so keep that in mind as we're
thinking about the impacts of management
on yields which is what i will show you
in a minute but i wanted to highlight
another pattern so these are global maps
i have corn plotted here on the top and
wheat on the bottom these are just two
of the crops that i
chose to show you as an example
and then observations are here
on the left
and the clm simulations are here on the
right
and part of the reason why i chose corn
is because it highlights this really
interesting pattern that we see in all
crops but is much more evident in corn
and it's that we underestimate yields in
temperate ecosystems and over
overestimate yields in tropical regions
and i think part of the underestimation
in temperate regions is really due to
that lack of intensification so we're
not getting those new cultivars those
new planting densities so we're
underestimating yields in a lot of these
regions
um we're overestimating yields in a lot
of tropical regions and i think that
this is because we don't
include
the fact that
pests you know we have additional pest
damage or potential extreme events that
we can't mitigate in a lot of these
regions we don't have pesticides
herbicides or insect outbreaks that
really
do affect these crops in tropical
regions because often times they're not
managed as intensively as in some of the
temperate regions
okay so how has no
knowing that there are these caveats how
has management impacted crop yields
so what i'll show you is the management
impacts on global grain production
through time um
and i i guess i just want to start by
saying that
you know i've never seen
global estimates of the impact of
management on crop yields so to me this
was a really exciting result and an
exciting new feature of a model like the
community land model that we could use
to try and understand how management
might impact
agricultural yields
and so i'll start here by showing this
green line this is clm5 it's the same as
the black line in the previous figure
that you saw so you can see that there's
this
leveling out
that is
that means that we're underestimating
yields for the uh end of
end of the time series here
um
next i'll highlight that when we
turn off irrigation so when we do not
irrigate crops we get this um
this decrease in yields that we see here
but even more impactful is this change
in crop yields based on fertilizer so
fertilizer is having a larger impact
than irrigation
perhaps not surprising because your
fertilizer is more widely applied
applied to agricultural regions than
irrigation there's actually a lot of
rain fed crops of
agriculture is about 10 of the land
surface and within that 10 of the land
surface
only 20 of the crop areas are irrigated
so it's a small area um and this is
actually quite a large impact on yields
given that small area
but fertilizer is more widely applied
and so we see a much larger impact of
fertilizer
similar in size is the impact of
cropland expansion and i have to compare
cropland expansion effect to a
simulation without fertilizer and
irrigation because when we don't allow
crop area to expand we're also not
getting any irrigation or any
fertilization on that crop area so the
crops are not seeing
um
you know so we wouldn't see croplet or
fertilization or irrigation so that's
that's the koplan expansion effect we
can also infer a bit of effect from
climate change including warmer
temperatures and carbon dioxide
concentrations by
looking at this stimulation that held
the held crop area constant at the
beginning
to the end and you can see that that
impact of co2 fertilization
and
um
temperature change is is relatively
small granted this is not including
irrigation or
fertilization
effects and so it's it's potentially
smaller that's
it's an inferred
inferred change but it's not it's not
nearly as large as the impact of
cropland expansion or fertilization or
irrigation so climate change has
increased crop yields a little bit but
not nearly as much as agricultural
management
okay so that that's a little bit about
how we represent agriculture and clm and
also
how agricultural management has changed
crop yields through time
and so i'll just highlight that tlm is
the first comprehensive representation
of agriculture in an earth system model
so this is a really exciting new
development
clm also simulates crop yields
relatively well but it doesn't include
agriculture intensification or weed and
pest management so that results in an
underestimation of crop yields in
temperate regions and an overestimation
of crop yields in
tropical regions
and then last
global crop yields have increased most
due to cropland expansion and industrial
fertilization but there is also a large
impact of irrigation as well that is
potentially going to be more important
as climate continues to warm
okay so now i will switch into
the last topic which is how does
agriculture change seasonal patterns of
carbon dioxide fluxes and what we'll
find in this is the agricultural
management is actually also a really
important component
of
how agriculture influences these carbon
dioxide fluxes
so i want to go back to this figure
again into thinking about the annual
cycle of carbon dioxide because this is
what i'm going to be focusing on and so
remember that during the northern
hemisphere growing season we see a
drawdown of carbon dioxide
due to plant uptake of that carbon
dioxide and the change in the
top and bottom so the peak to trough
change is what i'm calling the seasonal
amplitude
and the reason that i'm highlighting
this is because the seasonal amplitude
has increased through time so this is a
paper um
by graven and colleagues that's showing
the change in seasonal amplitude to two
sites at barrow alaska and also at
monoloa and what you'll notice is that
that
amplitude is changing through time so
the growing season there's more there's
more drawdown or more respiration that's
changing
that annual cycle
so what contributes to that changing
carbon dioxide amplitude
several things um there's been a lot of
research on this topic
enhanced seasonal carbon dioxide
exchange is caused by
um
increased productivity in northern
ecosystems so warmer temperatures is
increasing plant productivity
potentially contributing to that
drawdown and part of that is you know
you saw the larger
increase in amplitude and barrow than
you did at mauna loa and so this is
driving this
um
the result here
there's also
there's also carbon dioxide
fertilization and land use chain that's
contributing you know as
uh trees are growing more and more
northern latitudes we found that carbon
dioxide and
um the higher carbon dioxide
concentrations and also that northward
movement of trees is contributing to the
seasonal amplitude
and then there's some research that also
shows that agriculture is an important
part of the carbon dioxide amplitude
and that's important because most earth
system models are not actually capturing
these trends in amplitude and so you see
the observations here
um and then all of the er system models
that were used in the coupled model
intercomparison project version five
which was run for the last ipcc report
that um
all of those models
are are underestimating that change in
amplitude so you see none of them are
capturing this at all
and one of the reasons is because these
models none of these models included
agriculture
but in
the sea cmit 5 that those older version
of the cement models is we used the
community or system model one which had
generic crop representation where crops
function similarly to c3 grasses this is
what all all our system models were
using in cement five and cesm is the
only earth system model that now
includes managed crops and the newer
version cmip6 so the coupled model inter
comparison project version 6.
so
in cesm2
as we just saw crops are managed they're
planted they're harvested they're
irrigated they're fertilized and this
does have a large impact on terrestrial
processes i didn't show you that in the
last section but
but it does change fluxes of carbon
fluxes of water between the land and the
atmosphere
and so if we look at trends in carbon
dioxide amplitude in these two different
versions of the model they're improved
in cesm2 so the observations are plotted
here in black
at all of these different sites so i
chose a uh
latitudinal transect kuma kahi and
monoloa are actually both in hawaii so
they're both tropical sites and then you
have nywatt ridge which is in colorado
and barrow which is in alaska
and what um there's a few things that i
want to point out one is that the purple
line is cesm2 and so that always has a
higher amplitude than cesm1
which is shown in the
in the orange line
um
and at kumukahi and barrow
the csm gets the
matches these observations really really
well
why why are we still underestimated at
mauna loa and nywat ridge this is
because these two sites are at much
higher elevation they're both around 14
000 feet
and what we found is that the vertical
transport of carbon dioxide is still not
modeled very well in cesm and so you're
not getting that vertical transport
of carbon dioxide up and we can see that
by comparing pumakahi and monoloa both
of which fall in the same grid cell in
the model
so both are using
the same co2 concentrations
um or the the same
the same site
to look at the co2 amplitude with
different atmosphere layers so what you
can see is the higher atmosphere layer
has a much lower
co2 amplitude so that's one reason why
we're not matching at some of these
higher sites
i did look at actually a total of 40
sites in almost all of the sites look
very similar
where observations match the sea or
where the csm2 simulations match the
observations relatively well
so i wanted to know could this
improvement be in part due to
agriculture and what i found is that
the answer is yes
and specifically agricultural
fertilization and so i will show you
next
the impact that agricultural nitrogen
fertilization has
on this carbon dioxide amplitude so this
is the change in carbon dioxide
amplitude so that change from peak to
trough
in the coupled community or system model
um
so this is
a in you'll see in these um
agriculturally dominated regions you're
getting an increase in co2 amplitude of
about nine parts per million which is
actually pretty
pretty large overall change in aggregate
amplitude so this is a simulation a
fully coupled simulation where i took
agricultural fertilization and i just
turned it off and then i ran that
simulation and compared it to a
simulation that had
agricultural fertilization turned on
you get a very similar amplitude i
should say when you just simulate crops
as generic crops and cesm2 you had a
very similar change here and so i'm
showing you here in the land only model
so this is net biome production
amplitude net biome production is the
net flux of carbon from terrestrial
ecosystems to the atmosphere so it's
actually
the
carbon cycle variable that is passed
from the land surface
into the atmosphere in this model
and so what you see is that you do see a
large
change in amplitude of net biome
production or mvp in very similar
regions you see these large changes in
cesm2 but the changes look less
widespread
in some in some senses you're not seeing
some of the changes in the higher
latitudes it's actually a little hard to
see on this screen but there are
blue
areas that are changing you know in the
one to three amplitude
throughout most of north america in
these simulations that you don't don't
get here in clm5 and that's just because
we don't have atmospheric transport
in
the land model when you're looking at
land only simulations
but it's the nbp or the net biome
production that is causing these changes
in co2 amplitude
here in this top simulation
so i want to point this out because i'm
going to use land only simulations next
to think about how climate change carbon
dioxide and other management practices
might also change the amplitude
of carbon dioxide and so like i said i'm
going to switch to land only model
and we're going to isolate the impact
of fertilization and irrigation
management in these models or in this
model and also
elevated carbon dioxide and climate and
so climate is just temperature and
precipitation
and other
other meteorological variables but not
the carbon dioxide so those are
separated
like i said we're going to be looking at
net biome production which is the net c
flux the net carbon flux between the
land and the atmosphere
so this plot is showing that biome
production amplitude
the y
um i've started the plots in 1950 and
run through 2015 which is when the model
simulations ended they should also
highlight that i'm only looking at the
land area in the northern hemisphere
above 30 degrees north because that was
the only region that was impacted by
the
um
that's really the region that's driving
the changes in amplitude
okay so here are the results and what
i'll start with first is this line this
purple line clm5 so this is the change
in that biome production amplitude in
clm5
if you look at the impact of irrigation
that's the sort of yellowy orangey line
and you'll notice that without
irrigation you do see a small decrease
in net biome production but it's not
it's not very large and similar to what
i mentioned
in earlier in the talk irrigated area is
actually really small
and so when you do see the impact of
irrigation and i have maps
that i've looked at the impact of
irrigation is on the same order of
magnitude as the impact of fertilization
it's just isolated to a very small area
and i think that this is likely to
become more important under future
climate change as we expand the
irrigated areas in response to warmer
and drier conditions
climate change also does have an impact
and so this the difference between the
purple line and this sort of reddish
pink line
um that's the impact of climate change
and so this is these are warmer
temperatures um
the impact is is primarily in the
northern latitudes
carbon dioxide elevated carbon dioxide
concentrations also have an impact and
this impact is actually larger than the
impact of the temperature and
precipitation changes
and it really starts to become evident
in the you know in the 1980s
onward that impact of co2
on that biome production amplitude so
you are also seeing this
impact of carbon dioxide in a lot of
places globally it's just not as it
doesn't have as large of a magnitude in
any of the locations as some of the
other management factors
and so the last that i will show you is
the impact of fertilizer and this has
fertilizer has a very large impact on
that biome production i believe it's
this is almost a 50
change in net biome production amplitude
due to fertilization versus
if you look at co2 it's closer to a 40
percent change and if you look at
climate it's only a 15 to 20 change in
that biome production amplitude so
agricultural fertilization is changing
those fluxes of carbon back to the
atmosphere enough that we're seeing
a change in the seasonal cycle of carbon
dioxide so that just really highlights
how large of an impact agriculture has
on our climate system and if we really
want to understand
these climate carbon feedbacks that are
driving climate change we need to
include agriculture we need to consider
that
okay so does agriculture change that co2
fluxes it does
the carbon dioxide amplitude increases
more
in cesm2 which includes the active
representation of agriculture than it
does in cesm1
it also contributes to the
increased
seasonal amplitude
and this is primarily due to
industrial nitrogen fertilization
and last i i do want to highlight that
carbon dioxide and
climate change have also contributed to
that increasing amplitude just not to
the same magnitude as agricultural
management okay
so now i'll just wrap up and i'll
just leave you with some i guess key
thoughts how does human management of
agriculture
in terrestrial ecosystems change climate
um so i showed you that crop production
in in terms of crop production
management especially cropland expansion
and fertilizer increases crop yields
i also showed you that their
biogeophysical impacts that we also need
to consider of agriculture and so i
highlighted an example using copper
crops
and thinking about how if we plant
shorter or more sparse cover crops you
can minimize the effect of winter
warming and then last
i highlighted the agriculture especially
nitrogen fertilization
changes the seasonal carbon dioxide
fluxes and the amplitude of that and so
really in order to use these earth
system models to understand climate
change we need to include agriculture
agriculture is really important for
climate it's important for changing
energy water and carbon fluxes back to
the atmosphere and so we need to
include these processes in these models
and use these models to better
understand how agriculture can influence
climate and that will help us
figure out how to
better
think about
agricultural management as a climate
mitigation tool into the future
so
oh i guess i
doubled that slide
so we just want to end by really
highlighting that models like the
community land model and the community
air system model can be used to answer
exciting questions at
both at site
regional and also at global scales
and thinking about things like what
resource limitations and challenges will
we face in the future
how can management contribute to climate
change
and how can
management be used to mitigate or
minimize the climate impacts while
maintaining yields so you can use a
model like cesm and clm to address these
questions
we absolutely need to integrate
observations and ecological theory in
order to improve our understanding to
improve the representation of these
processes but we can use models as this
useful tool to really understand what
those climate impacts and interactions
are so i will just end there and i'm
happy to take any questions
thank you very much for this exciting
talk
i was wondering um
does plant breeding germplasms
herbicides pesticides play a role
anywhere it didn't pop up so i'm either
we need to abolish the plant breeding
department or it's somewhere in there
it's probably lumped in one of the other
effects and i was wondering where are
they and does it make sense are there
efforts to
to parcel this out to figure this out
and the second question is
are you using or do you want to use or
does anybody use ai in
these
endeavors and where and how does do you
think there's an opportunity great um
great questions and so
yes we um we do not need to abolish the
plant breeding department
but uh you know i i mean genetics is is
a really important component and i think
that where that shows up is the fact
that clm does not capture or does not
include anything related to
plant breeding and and changes in
cultivar
and so we're we're missing that yield
increase at the end of the 21st century
or the 20th century sorry um and so
we're not really seeing that large
increase in part because we don't
capture those processes and so i think
that we need to incorporate them and
then talking to ying during my visit
i've um i recently learned that she's
actually working on some of those exact
questions
yeah and so uh so i'm excited to to get
to think about how we might be able to
incorporate some of those processes into
clm
related to ai and machine learning
we're not doing it yet but i absolutely
think it's going to be an important
component and this is actually what i
mentioned to you yesterday one example
is in thinking about plant breeding and
cultivar how are we
how how can we incorporate those changes
through time and we can use machine
learning for example or we we can
consider using machine learning to think
about how those things are changing
through time because we can't in a
global scale model it's really hard to
include all of the different cultivars
and how they've changed through time but
if we can use some machine learning or
ai applications to think about how those
things have changed through time and to
guide
those
representations you know maybe those are
parameter changes so the parameters are
sort of the constant variables that
affect different aspects of crop yields
as represented in the model and so if we
could change some of those things to
represent the changes in cultivars and
changes in
you know different aspects of plant
growth
you know i think that that's one
exciting application one example that i
can think of at the top of my head
okay
i found your model uh
predicting that
cover crops would cause an increase in
temperature in the vicinity of central
minnesota and
saskatchewan
and um
i'm wondering whether your modeling is
uh restricted to the above
above ground above the snow temperature
or whether you've also had model
modeling of the
soil temperature
and my reason for asking is that for
decades we have been advising farmers
to leave stubble
over winter because it will catch snow
and the snow will provide an insulating
layer
it will also prevent the snow from being
a lot of wind in this region
and so it
holds the snow as opposed to having snow
drift away leaving their soil so i'm
wondering whether you took into account
those taxes yes
those are
these are all really fantastic questions
and those are processes that we are
absolutely missing in the model we don't
um we don't have wind drifted snow we
don't include that we do include soiled
temperatures but the soil temperatures
are not changing in response to root
growth it's another process that is just
missing in the model and so we need
those are all things that we need to
include and that i think will
increase our confidence in these model
simulations and so that um the cover
crop temperature change
what
what i showed there is there's an
increase in wintertime temperatures
i would not say this is absolutely
what's going to happen because we know
of all of these limitations and also it
was a very idealized scenario and just
looking at the above ground
processes not we didn't change the soil
temperature and like i said the soil
temperature doesn't change in response
to root growth which i think is an
important missing component
and as far as the physical processes of
catching snow i also recognize that that
is a very important process but no we do
not include that in the model so
those are things that i think need to be
considered and will be important in
future studies
a lot of your model runs are showing
validation runs up to recent past
because he wants to use appearance in
the future
and
agriculture and climates are a couple
systems
about how
so
i mean great question the short answer
is no we don't have that and the way
that we're trying to account for human
decision changes is by running future
scenarios
and those are using the different
socioeconomic
pathways
so they're more story lines and those
are developed for these future climate
scenarios they do include
you know what people think will happen
in response to climate change in terms
of that but there aren't those coupled
interactions and this is a there it was
actually
just in the you know the past year at a
workshop that was talking exactly about
this problem because it's really really
hard to
understand how human decisions are going
to change there's so many factors that
go into it that it's really not easy to
put into a large scale
sort of physical
or system model it's it's such a
challenge to try and understand how to
predict so there are prediction
models
that are trying to understand human
human interactions reactions to climate
change but they're typically separated
from these earth system models and um
trying to figure out how to better
integrate those besides just taking data
from one and passing it to another is a
huge challenge but it's it's something
that i think would be great to think
about um we are trying to start working
with social scientists a little bit more
and so
for example there's a current project at
ncar that is
with a social scientist who is going and
asking farmers questions about how
they're
dealing with
or how they're thinking about soil
health and what influences their
decisions and in that way we can try and
better understand some of these
interactions but we're still not quite
integrating human decisions into this
kind of model because most of the time
we're just getting that from external
integrated assessment models is what
they're called and pulling in that
the data from those models
but they didn't transfer from other
phases
and thinking how much trouble
comes from such a negative thing
yeah i that's it's another great
question and i think
it very much can come from international
trade these changes and carbon fluxes
but we don't include that again in the
model so what the way that the model
currently works is all of the carbon
that is in the grain is respired back to
the atmosphere over the course of a year
in the same location where it's
harvested and so we don't account for
that i think that we should we can
but it is it's another one of those sort
of economic
aspects where you need to know where
that carbon is going and how to think
about incorporating a process like that
into a model like this you know it's
another challenge it doesn't mean that
it's
insurmountable it just is another
challenge
um
so yeah we
we don't account for that at all and uh
we do have the atmospheric transport but
it is transporting the fluxes and i
think that that's
also part of the reason why you're
seeing the largest pulses or the largest
changes in co2 amplitude and also net
biome production amplitude in the
agriculture regions because that's where
the carbon is going
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu